dimanche mégane et harry était sur tous
les écrans de télé aux états unis pour
leurs interviews chocs soir cbs héros
diffusé hier soir sur tmc une interview
menée par la prêtresse de la télévision
oprah winfrey dans laquelle le couple
s'est totalement lâché le couple people
le plus sulfureux du moment expliqué en
détail et sans filtre les raisons de
leur départ de la famille royale et leur
choix de prendre de la distance avec
l'angleterre
je dois faire quelque chose pour ma
santé mentale celle de ma femme et pour
cet article
megan a également fait sensation en
évoquant une anecdote particulièrement
choquant sur les coulisses de son
accouchement elle a plus ouvertement des
membres de la famille royale de racisme
y avait aussi les inquiétudes et de
conversations sur la couleur de sa peau
quand il n'entrait une période difficile
pour toutes ces raisons mais aussi à
cause de l'immense pression médiatique
subie par le couple megan alors en
dépression n'aurait reçu aucune aide de
la part de la famille royale ne pouvons
rien faire pour vous protéger car vous
n'êtes pas une employée de cette
institution une interview qui ne risque
pas de réconcilier mégane et la reine et
qui aurait mis buckingham palace dans
tous ses états alors êtes vous plutôt
tine elisabeth outils mégane et harry
stéphane clarke écrivain anglais est
avec nous ce soir pour revenir sur cette
interview
merci stéphane 4 d'être avec nous au
grand spécialiste de la royauté vous
avez d'ailleurs sorti une bd et
d'isabelle 2 où l'humour souverain aux
éditions albin michel
vous avez regardez cette interview
franchement non franchement non
alors on va revoir quelques moments où
les extrêmes et pas est-ce qu'elle a été
bien accueillie au sein de la famille
royale cette interview un entraînement
très très mal justement ça a divisé le
pays en deux ah ouais a complètement
willy à l'oeil et le team comme vous le
dites si elle team am alive mégane
qu'est-ce qu'il a dû souffrir ces
pauvres jeunes femmes et à la team à la
pauvre princesse
qu'est-ce qu'elle était malheureuse dans
son palais avec son prince
et il ya la reine qui jouent le jeu
complètement au milieu parce qu'elle
était subtil à la reine à elle a sorti
ce soir elle a sorti un statement un
truc où elle dit que que les accusations
de racisme sont très préoccupantes mais
peut-être que les gens se souviennent
pas très bien de ce qui s'est vraiment
passé alors qu'elle a joué le jeu
accusations de racisme c'est un des
extraits les plus forts de cette
interview c'est interview voilà puisque
d'après eux la pour la possible pour
foncer darchy leur premier enfant a fait
l'objet de nombreuses discussions
voilà là pendant ma grossesse il parlait
entre nous deux fait qu'il n'aurait
aucune sécurité qui n'auraient pas de
titre et il y avait aussi des
inquiétudes et des conversations sur la
couleur de sa peau quand ils mettraient
il y a une conversation avec vous avec
un repas sur la couleur de la peau de
votre bébé
potentiellement ce que ça impliquerait
de quoi ça aurait l'air alors c'est vrai
que ça c'est un des extraits et plus
plus fort est ce que vous croyez à ces
accusations de racisme de racisme
pas vraiment amener les anglais je pense
qu'ils sont tous assez d'accord que ça
fait longtemps maintenant que la reine a
compris que la famille ol ne peut
absolument pas être raciste avant le
prince philip
il était connu pour ses très mauvaises
blagues d'accord à très louche très
douteuse du genre
il a dit à une équipe d'étudiants
anglais en chine mais c'est pas trop
long
sinon vous aurez les yeux [ __ ] aller à
une image comme ça spectacle et c'était
le plus vieux stand-up anglais et
maintenant ils arrêter mais et la reine
la faf bien fait comprendre que non ça
se sent comme un pou ding les faux il
faut pas il faut pas faire ce genre de
truc et ça fait longtemps qu'il a été
donc six mois comme beaucoup de anglais
en est convaincu qu'il n'y a pas d'airé
16 racisme dans la mer ou air et petit
le contraire et au petit à l'époque
quantis un camp mais gainey un oui ce
sont marie on avait l'impression qu'ils
étaient quand même jean soulagé enfin
quelqu'un va pouvoir aller dans les
banlieues difficiles et montrer qu'on
n'est pas juste un bon vieux gaulle
c'était c'était alors un objet politique
c'est alors y'a meghan markle qui est
également revenu sur les difficultés
qu'elle a rencontrées au sein de la
famille royale
privé de liberté la duchesse a expliqué
qu'elle serait tombée en dépression et
aurait songé au pire regardé et j'ai dit
que j'avais vraiment besoin des jobs à
ce qu'ils ont dit nous sommes de tout
coeur avec vous car nous voyons bien
quel point c'est difficile mais nous ne
pouvons rien faire pour vous protéger
car vous n'êtes pas une employée cette
institution vous aviez des pensées
suicidaires
oui c'était un très très clair on peut
pas simplement partir comme ça il faut
bien comprendre que quand j'ai intégré
la famille ça a été la dernière fois
jusqu'à notre arrivée ici parce que j'ai
vu mon passeport mon permis de conduire
mes clés alors ajoute pas un peu l1
ouais
voyez une partie des anglais qui est
sans arrêt en train de pleurer toute la
journée à la 35e mais en angleterre n'a
pas le droit de dire ça d'une princesse
mais on peut déjà plus subtilement comme
le dit la n1 peut-être qu'elle se
souvient peut pas très bien de ce qui se
passait à l'époque parce que quand on
lui enlève par exemple ses clés de
voiture elle s'en plaint pas quand elle
bat west hollywood et on donne les clés
à quelqu'un pour la guerre il avait
travaillé salle que l'alors tous les
avantages elles sont plaint pas mais
l'inconvénient de changement et mais ce
qui était peut-être vrai c'est que
pauwels adultes compte tellement étrange
et les eti star hollywoodienne soit sur
ista lydienne tout le monde vous obéit
leur arrive dans un palais où elle est
juste la petite dernier
et où sont plus considérés oui surtout
dans ses palais là il faut être super
poli et super sympathique envers le
personnel ouais la reine enfin une
fierté de traiter les gens avec
politesse et vous savez il ya des
plaintes contre mégane qui n'ont pas été
prouvées mais qu'ils étaient des
employés qui disent que les à maltraiter
doit leur parler mal c'était juste une
star hollywoodienne qui arrive dans un
palais masse et sa royale à on lui
assigne le pouvoir ce n'est pas
hollywood tu va redescendre de deux
états tout va bien avait un resto ni ma
belle alors il ya un extrait café qui a
énormément amusé les téléspectateurs
c'est lorsque harry et mégane se sont
rendus avec oprah winfrey dans un
poulailler
on a ainsi pu voir le prince harry
nourrir des poules l'autre c'est un
mytho 2009 on a mis nos bottes pour
nourrir les pistes que megan et harry
ont récemment sauvée d'une exploitation
agricole
j'adore cette maison là c'est trop
mignon
elle a toujours voulu des poules oui
j'adore sauver les animaux
donc ça fait partie de votre nouvelle
vie qu'est ce qu'ils font se lève plus
qu est ce qui vous passionne
je crois simplement pouvoir vivre de
façon authentique ce genre de choses
c'est si simple et si enrichissant sa
nou na waie
non mais ça c'est très authentique c'est
authentiquement hollywoodien californien
limites mais n'ont jamais nourri une
poule c les coûts moyens
la piètre qualité des doublages c'était
terrible c'était même leur dire voilà
pour juillet s'accentuer le côté saaq
sont à mes côtés le mal joué des
séquences et le côté surjouée en croit
une telenovelas un peu maintenant alors
dsk
ils sont ils vont faire quoi alors c'est
dollars justement il se fit se plaignent
est exclue du système mais leur seule
façon de gagner un salaire et y ait des
cuves exclus parce que la compagnie dont
la famille royale continue ou noyés de
la fin l'ol on n'a pas le droit de
gagner un salaire donc en sortant
maintenant ils peuvent gagner un salaire
ils peuvent par exemple vendre
l'autobiographie ou leurs livres de psy
ou dieu sait quoi et gagner des millions
d'accord donc ils vont révéler millions
à 800 jean pierre foucault comme ça
comme ça tout seul rien merci nous
habite à londres où nos anges habite à
paris paris adacore sympa merci en tout
cas